hey guys what's up I'm here we fought
strength and conditioning coach Chris
Grayson has been studying nutrition and
involved in the health and fitness for
how long now since 99 his ninety nine a
long time he just introduced me to a
book I was amazed it's called a hundred
50 healthiest foods on earth and we I
noticed here that one thing is there's
nothing in there
there's no coca-cola no okay there's
nothing on ice cream no there's nothing
on cookies and much of the standardized
Western diet right isn't that in there
but there's but there's everything that
the Creator has given us some natural
foods let's go to the one there's so
many but the dates and the dates he went
on two dates welcome these foods aren't
in there the standard things that we
used to eat there's because they're not
good for you and you know anybody that
doesn't mean research should know this
anything in this book is good and you
should be eating this stuff so this is a
great resource but these are real food
is all real food this is all real food
we got coconut what is this this is
cranberry what else keep going you know
there's eight states there we go we got
dates look at that so if you want
something sweet and set up a Snickers
bar or Hershey's uh what are these kiss
give yourself a kiss with a date huh and
you got vegetables in here so you got
all the sweet foods tons of vegetables
Wow tons of vegetables beets and it
what's cool is to anything you come
across it has a star oh he was like like
extra like extra good for you yeah
according to him and he has a PhD in
nutrition what I love about this guy's
he stays in academia and he he's not
he's unbiased this is not like a
religion he's he always looking for is
the truth
so he'll change his mind if there's a
good reason he'll change his opinion if
there's a good reason completely
unbiased just looking at that the the
evidence the science the research and
stays up to date with his own colleagues
and people in the industry that are the
best of the best and they're in their
field whether that's doctors whether
that's nutritionists whether that's
natural paths you name it we're hearing
a lot from from many holistic doctors
and people like yourself nutrition is
people who are really involved in the
health industry who've gone above and
beyond
they have telling us that the food is
affecting our health the fake foods what
is your thought on that oh yeah I think
I'm a victim of I've known these things
for a long time now so it's hard
sometimes to discuss something like that
because it seems I think I take it for
granted because I've known a lot of this
for a long long time so to me it's
common sense but yeah it's most
certainly affecting you it the problem
that we're in today isn't just the junk
food but the problem is we're putting
ammonium nitrate pesticides herbicides
fungicides on our soil the soil gets
depleted of minerals the plants have
deficiencies the animals that eat the
plants have deficiencies and we all have
deficiencies and these over time if they
don't get addressed ultimately they
develop into diseases and the problem
today is we're not looking for these
problems until they're a disease you
don't end up with type 2 diabetes
overnight there's that there's a
spectrum you end up glucose intolerant
insulin resistant diabetic if we paid
attention to this in the medical
profession we would catch these things
before they became issues but it's the
thing is it's a all these companies are
in cahoots with each other the
agricultural industry the chemical
industry the pharmaceutical industry
they're all in cahoots because if they
make deficiencies the chemical industry
puts the stuff on our on our crops the
crops have deficiencies what happens we
have deficiencies we go to our normal
doctor that learned Western medicine the
curriculum was provided by the
pharmaceutical industry we go to see him
we say hey I'm depressed or I'm sorry
not depressed I'm tired I'm fatigued
this actually happened to me once and
the doctor he says that's you're
depressed and you say why you know
that's a symptom of too
crushin fatigue then they try to put you
on a medication whether it be prozac
Zoloft paxil you name it they don't get
to the root problem of your probably
your fatigue because you your you have a
lack of lack of nutrition you have
deficiencies you maybe of gut issues you
have inflammation it can go on and on is
a good is a good start
to start eliminating all faked processed
foods and to eat real foods is that a
start a good start it's a great start
you know what I do with people in here
that come here see this is what happens
with what I do because I people come
here and they think exercises the answer
they think exercise is gonna solve all
their problems and I wish it did because
if I if it did I would own more gyms I'd
make more money and if I was gonna be a
liar I would tell the lie that yes
exercise is gonna make all the
difference but it's not its lifestyle
that makes the difference lifestyle
makes the difference so what I try to do
with people when they come here is give
them resources the problem is people
they don't have good resources so the
first thing I try to give them as good
resources what I love about this book is
it is a resource you don't have to read
this book cover to cover it's not like a
regular book like a novel that you read
from page one all the way through you
can jump around and you can learn about
all these different foods why they're
good you can learn a lot about the food
and you know that if it's in this book
you're gonna learn about it and you know
you can eat it so you're giving somebody
a good resource and that's the first
thing people have to have good resources
and then from there what I do from there
is I try to discover what's the one
thing that if they've changed is gonna
give them the biggest bang for their
buck or their biggest return on their
investment and their investment could be
time time as an investment correct so
identify what the one thing is and I try
to have them work on that one thing
because the problem today outside of
resources is we have habits it's not
always easy to change habits if somebody
came to me and they're eating Captain
Crunch or Lucky Charms for breakfast and
I told them to eat broiled sea bass and
a spare
I guess that might not be the best
advice because that might be too hard to
go from Captain Crunch to broiled sea
bass it's so you have to give people
advice and work on one thing so you
don't so it can be consistent for the
long term and it can be a part of their
life forever because the problem with
the diet when somebody says I'm on a
diet what that means is ultimately
they're gonna be off a diet that's a
problem because these things need to be
a part of your lifestyle for the rest of
your life so you got to find you got to
find things that are gonna work for you
forever so you can be consistent
long-term and compliant otherwise it's a
short it's a short fix so thank you so
much even though food avoid fake foods
there's some good advice it's great
advice thank you so much my pleasure all
right guys that was Chris Grayson my
strength and conditioning coach who's
been involved in health and nutrition
since the late 1990s so he's been
telling me a lot about this stuff for a
long time and now it's really starting
to sink in and I really over the years
now really really started to take it to
a new level and I'm trying to bring
these things to light to you and he
turned me out to this book that he was
mentioning when I first saw I was just
amazed I said Wow from the cover where
it says a hundred fifty healthiest foods
and then caught my attention also here
an endorsement by Fred cuz corty MD and
there's other medical doctors and that
was that's a good sign you know when you
have medical doctors conventional
medical doctors who are going above and
beyond and starting to study food and it
also helps you to be grateful alright it
connects you like wow this is like real
food who created the food you know you
start to develop the gratitude when you
really start to look into this food
let's go through this book real quick
I'm excited as you can see to to read
this book to go through it one of my
favorite favorite things to eat our
sweet potatoes alright this is a very
healthy real food let's go to something
else there's so many here you have Wow
these are all real foods that the
Creator has blessed us with and it
reminds me of the ayah in the Quran
where the Creator is telling us eat of
the techie back the good pure food that
this is the these are the foods and in
them you'll see their descriptions of
all of the health benefits now the
unique thing is you're not going to find
that with the fake foods you're not
gonna have any benefits from these toxic
foods that I'm trying to get the message
out that we should get out of the
mustards foods that are actually toxic
cancer causing diabetes causing heart
disease causing really bad foods so
replace them let's go let's look at for
instance brothers and sisters apples
look at that you've hold you've heard
the old cliche which actually ended up
being true look an apple a day keeps the
doctor away is a good example of one of
those old cliches that actually turns
out to be right according to dr. derma
and then it goes on looked at men who
eat one apple a day lower their risk of
heart attack by 32% look at that how
many how many doctors are recommending
that their patients eat organic apples
come on before the the drugs get
prescribed come on people
avoid fake food look at that we can be
bringing to the mustard apples how about
bananas look at that high in potassium
it's sweet and it's a real food
ding-ding-ding-ding-ding look at that
there's no fake foods here so you won't
hear me like our friend Jim Marlow on
the other video I posted where our fake
food these are all real foods let's move
on and see what else is in this book I'm
very excited that you can see because
we've gone away from eating the foods
that the crater's given us and we're
eating a lot of this garbage junk fake
but look at look you want something
sweet let's see what the author says
about dates you know it's a Sunnah the
Prophet peace be upon him Muhammad he
would he would eat dates and is
recommended look at this I've heard
dates described as nature's candy I
would look at that nature scan and I
think that description is on the money
because they are such an amazing source
of nutrients you can't get anywhere
al's look at that no they're on the list
because well let's face it we love
sweets oh if you love sweets look eat
dates that he goes on and if you're
going to eat sweets they might as well
come in a package that does minimal harm
and actually might do some good look
full of sugar but also full of nutrients
that's the difference it's not processed
refined man-made garbage and there's a
difference like my friend Chris was
saying but a person was able to consume
more dates the person who's actually
riding horseback or being active rather
than just sitting at a computer all day
goji berries that's another great food
to replace fat fake foods in the mustard
the goji berries look at this Oh
subhanAllah Brazil nuts Wow
Brazil nuts have the highest selenium
content of any food I know of and for
this reason alone belong belong among
the world's healthiest food and the list
goes on of all the benefits and again
you're not gonna if you open up a book
on coca-cola if you open a book on
Mountain Dew Pepsi you're not going to
find any benefits but do some research
we're gonna see all of the potential
harm that comes from these fake food
cookies cakes ice cream all the garbage
look at that you know I've been you know
look at that the the milk that the
Creator has given us raw not the
pasteurized homogenized milk subhanAllah
I know there's a lot of propaganda
against raw milk the same way there's a
lot of propaganda against the eggs
look I can't let's look at eggs I can't
say enough good things about eggs their
nature is most and I would put instead
of nature their gods right the creators
most perfect food eggs are plentiful
inexpensive easy to prepare in a zillion
different ways and loaded with vitamins
they're also one the best sources of
protein on the planet make sure they're
from healthy chickens organic
pasture-raised not from conventional
eggs look at that and we get into like
meats look free-range free-range what
does that mean not from these sick
chickens we move on if you go on we're
almost done grass-fed look one thing
hollow but also the people who are
selling the halal meat made sure the
animal is healthy what did Allah give
the animal to eat grass grass and more
grass look at that and if we eat from a
healthy animal of course look then we
should be healthy but not a sick animal
pumped with drugs and antibody could
it's sick and stressed and then you're
eating that meat of course people are
getting sick from that all right so we
have liver Oh
let's go but liver is really a great
food in fact gram for gram it contains
more nutrients than any other food the
most bang for your body said hate liver
but once i readed my taste buds to go
ahead and reverse the process of
actually eating to live instead of
living to eat and ask you myself how can
this benefit me then I start to eat go
good clothes from foods the real foods a
couple more and then let's olives this
is a familiar fruit huh this is also
mentioned as one of the healthiest foods
Oh
sauerkraut this is one of my favorites a
great natural look non-pasteurized of
course and this is a great probiotic
sauerkraut there are too many to list
one from the sea vegetable here
according to PhD Linda see plants are
get our gifts from the sea they're a
gift from the Creator to us these foods
are a gift for us that nurture us how
about this
one guys avocados this is another one of
the foods I really enjoy eating let's
see what the author has to say
avocados are an amazing food but until
recently you'd never know it
avocados were almost a casualty of the
fatphobia that swept the nation back in
the 1980s that fatphobia has not yet
died as much deserved death but there
are promising signs that it's dying out
which is good news for those of us
trying to redeem the reputation of this
glorious high-fat foods that are really
really good look you want a natural
antibiotic garlic is a global remedy
it's one of the oldest medicinal foods
on the planet
oh we know there's a ton of misuse on
antibiotics you go to the to the doctor
see he sees you for five minutes six
minutes seven minutes and gives you an
antibiotic and overuse of them
so my recommendation guys as I've been
saying eat real food avoid junk fake
food all right guys so I wanted to share
that with you simple message eat real
food
avoid fake food very simple easy to
understand and let's get this fake food
out of the mustards I mentioned some of
the things that we can replace it with
and that is the kind of thing the things
that we can do to to prevent inshallah
God willing the diseases and the
sickness and at the end of the day after
we've tried everything in our power then
we leave our trust to the Almighty and a
person can under on the flip side do
everything they can and then they get
sick but at the end of the day they did
they did everything they can let's do
everything we can in this aspect to not
poison our children and ourselves with
much of this toxic junk the fake foods
and put the real foods in our body the
foods that are a healing for our body
and will be of benefit for our bodies in
our health
thank you guys Salaam alaikum and
I think don't forget this Saturday
December 23rd we have former chief
nutritionists for dr. Mercola Jim Marlow
he's been studying nutrition for 40
years
also dr. Hashimoto Savage they'll be at
da roca on health which way have you
headed we're gonna be learning some of
the basics of food real food and
nutrition and then there'll be a great
Q&A you can ask your questions so try
your best to bring you and your family
and I want to see more of this I want
this to take off we're more mustards are
educating community leaders people with
a voice this is a great way to help
people by educating people because it's
affecting us all hundred thousand people
now hundred million people now in the
u.s. are pre the pre-diabetic on their
way to get diabetes or diabetic heart
disease inflammation of the body leading
to chronic diseases kids adults are sick
we become a sick nation so as Muslims we
need to be on the front line educating
people educating the community about
what they can do before it hits home and
for many people that has hip hop at home
and many of these diseases are
reversible with proper nutrition with
proper lifestyle change commitment to it
but many people don't know these simple
these simple solutions so it starts with
education started in your mustards if
you do will help to promote it and show
a lot it can be act of ibadah because
you're being a benefit you're inviting
to something good something wholesome
something pure something simple
educating people on eating real food
avoiding fake food I hope to see you at
our Quran December 23rd at 1:00 p.m.
make sure you're there and if you do one
of these that you're must chit send us
the flyer will help insha'Allah to
promote it Salaam alaikum